from day one I've always wondered to how
and why for the way things work and
always wanted to just build things and
build something new build something that
also is not just building technology for
the sake of building cool technology but
something that really adds value to the
world I just have a lot of curiosity I'm
Austin Russell I'm 22 and founder and
CEO of lumen are at lumen are were
making a new type of lidar sensor to
allow autonomous vehicles to see and
understand the world around them in very
high detail we're here to enable these
autonomous vehicles to finally become a
reality and at scale and most
importantly be safe
to allow them to not just see like some
objects some of the time but all objects
all of the time which is critical to go
from getting something that works like
99% of the time to the 10 9s that you
really need at the end of that to create
something that is truly safe and is
better than human level capabilities we
had the foresight to build something
completely from the ground up you know
to target an industry that five years
ago a lot of people think you know
wasn't even necessarily going to happen
I think it takes an incredible amount of
imagination and critical thinking to
start from the ground up rather than
just using existing and off-the-shelf
parts and tools to help build these
systems we were really focused on
building up a product that worked and
wanted to show the world the major
advantage that we made rather than just
an idea on a post-it note when you
intersect interdisciplinary innovations
and a lot of curiosity passion and drive
you can come up with something truly
incredible and you know maybe some
people define that as genius but I'm
just always interested in learning
[Music]
you